you have any plans to visit the Border
not in the near term no no it's just be
disruptive not anything else yeah
why aren't you going to go to the Border
well it would just be disruptive that's
absolutely true Republicans love to
pretend that the only way to manage the
situation on the border is for Joe Biden
to go and to do a photo op and to
inspect the Border fence and this sort
of thing why do they think that well
because that's what they expect from the
Republican politicians who do those
types of photo ops all the time they
bring a desk they put it so absurd the
visuals they bring a desk and put it at
the border and sit there and say we're
meeting we're meeting with border patrol
oh but really what you're doing is
you're actually creating a lot of
logistical work for security and all
travel all these different things the
allegation initially was when title 42
expires it'll be a disaster
it hasn't happened now they're shifting
to why won't Biden go to the border and
Biden rightly says because it'll just
become a distraction